you see Andy will you not tell him I'm
here okay because of what happened I
don't want him to think stop don't want
to know the less I know about other
people's Affairs the happier I am I'm
not interested in caring about people I
once worked with a guy for 3 years and
never learned his name best friend I
ever
had we still never talk
sometimes this came out yeah I am
starving I haven't had lunch since
yesterday so I'm going to head over to
callahans oh no no no don't go there
they totally skimp on pickles let me go
to big head Joe's for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food no no no trust me they have
one that's called the meat tornado
literally killed the guy last year you
had me at meat
tornado Pier garan was a six round pick
kie was a four fourth round Indianapolis
Colts know how to draft so well they
really do Andy this was delicious it's
awesome huh it's a whole new meat
delivery system thank you son what do
you say we go out to the parking lot run
a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an Unstoppable good
idea
machine I like Andy I'm surrounded by a
lot of women in this department and that
includes the men
up
up pton Manning reading the defense
Reggie Wayne P
Corner Andy wait up libertarianism is
all about individual liberty and it
should never be defined by the terms
liberal or conservative and communism is
no good that's right big swing in a miss
yeah and what's the word for when a few
clerics are in
charge religious oligarchy
holy I can remember things I
guess hey keep M rare a man after my own
heart
Ron
Ron last name
d is that your name or are you telling
me you're finished talking
both
done and
done I like
Ron Now That's What I Call shooting is
this a hunting game yeah it's fine you
want to play indeed I do if you'd like I
can offer you some pointers hunting
Donna is about silence balance and
patience get
ready
you know you're supposed to hit the deer
right get it together
Sanson hunting No Quarters
required hang on do you have a license
to hunt at night cuz you need a
license
I thought you were serious come on now
you know I don't give a fresh air real
weapons and honest
kill there is no substitute for the real
thing you want to go back and play that
video game don't you yes damn
it oh come on come on come on now that's
what I call shooting that's a new record
he look at that you finally made it in
the top 10 now you can enter your
initials my initials are private well
then just put in any three
letters
ass would you like to sample our vegan
bacon 100% meatless yes
please another
please sir is there a problem I'm just
making sure no one ever has to eat this
I I don't think I can give you anymore I
want
one I love food and
stuff it's where I buy all of my
food and most of my
stuff hey can I get these how much are
they two bucks a piece good
deal anything else nope just the crows
and the
beef you bean bag come with me I'm an
eggplant I don't care come with me why I
need small
hands
I'm scared there I think I got it yep
you got
it
can you at least tell me what you're
doing I'm a homeowner I would like to
actually learn
something yeah I'm tightening the valve
stem into the valve shank I'm replacing
the handle and then tightening the set
screw which will hold it in place
now oh my God we made it work it's a
good feeling sense of accomplishment and
pride damn it I just love it so
much are you okay great I'm going to go
around this house and fix everything I
can find that needs fixing you want to
help I really do good that's
next excuse
us ah nice form son make sure you keep a
firm pressure on the cranium on the
cranium listen up I have to turn off the
power for one minute we're going to go
dark people bear with us okay we got to
switch off the main fuse hose it's just
a fuse it's just a fuse people just a
fuse i' say you got the handle on that
torque wrench yeah well the flange was a
little warped so I just goosed it with
the triple 3 bolts Mac that was nonsense
I know but it's so fun to talk like that
you know
what keep
this you earned it thanks
Ron Donna this is crazy typhoon is an
artist and the human head is his canvas
just listen you're going to cut the
man's hair you're going to charge him $8
it'll take you 4 minutes so just shut up
and make the man look like this
fine so
typhoon what do you like to do for fun
I'm writing an electronic Opera about
Britney Murphy and I do the chandelier
design for my friend's drag puppet show
no further questions all I really want
to do is dance except lately all the
good Warehouse Raves are filled with
Euro trash
Euro trash I like that it is indeed a
garbage continent yes oh my God I had
the worst time in Berlin last May
everyone was on their stupid bikes I was
like
ew please talk more about how you hate
Europe in
bicycles you know you are a wonderful
guy and I admire many things about you
but you're a terrible person to discuss
personal problems with thank you friend
that really means a lot to me
go